- So what'd you do last night?
- Yo, I watched the game.
- Man, I wanted to watch the game so bad,
but my girlfriend made
me watch The Bachelor.
- Yeah?
- Yeah.
- You know, I actually only
watched part of the game
'cause my girlfriend also
made me watch The Bachelor.
- Huh.
(playful music)
- Yeah, my girlfriend
thinks Ben's pretty cool.
- I mean, my girlfriend likes him,
but she doesn't buy the whole,
"I'm unloveable." thing, you know.
- Yes, my girlfriend agrees.
- See what my girlfriend
doesn't understand is
why Ben keeps Lace around.
- Well, my girlfriend thinks it 'cause of
the producers you know.
To keep the show more interesting.
- Oh.
I guess my girlfriend
never thought about that.
- I don't know.
My money's on Tubilee.
My girlfriend's money.
- What?
No way.
Not with Olivia still hanging around.
That's my girlfriend's thought.
- [Voiceover] Shh.
- [Both] Sorry.
- Who's your girlfriend's
favorite to win the show?
One, two, three.
Emily.
- Ann.
- [Both] What?
- How'd your girlfriend react when LB
just walked off the show?
- My girlfriend thought she was insane.
- Right?
- I mean like that's a once
in a lifetime opportunity.
- Like my girlfriend would
kill to be on that show.
- Yeah, my girlfriend also.
Excuse us, sir.
We're gonna need you to hold.
- See my girlfriend's top
four fantasy picks are
Lauren H., Lauren B., Becca, and Jojo.
- But what about Amanda.
She has two kids.
They would make a
beautiful family with Ben.
At least that's what my girlfriend thinks.
- I guess.
You know what?
We're gonna do the deal.
- I mean honestly, my
girlfriend thinks Ben
is better than Sean.
- Is your girlfriend crazy?
Better than Sean?
Sean was the perfect fit for Caitlyn.
Are you kidding me?
Ben and Caitlyn together?
They would've been in divorce court
after three months.
Sean was the perfect person for Caitlyn.
He was a strong, strapping young man
that's perfect, that just fits perfectly.
Ben would've just like been boiling down.
You're a freaking idiot.
Your girlfriend's dumb for thinking that.
That's what my girlfriend thinks.
'Cause I definitely don't watch the show.
(techno music)